je m'appelle viviane payet benhamida
j'ai 46 ans je suis enseignante
spécialisée dans l'accueil des élèves
allophones alors allophones ça veut dire
dont la langue maternelle est différente
que le français et je suis conseiller
départemental sur saint-andré dans le
canton numéro 5
alors le canton s'attendre et 2 comprend
le centre ville de saint-andré une
partie de la cressonnière ravine-creuse
rivière du mât les bas à champ-borne
chemin du centre et une partie de petit
bazar alors pourquoi je suis attaché à
ce canton d'abord j'ai grandi à
saint-andré et puis ensuite j'ai
travaillé pendant 14 ans dans la
politique de la ville j'ai travaillé
avec les habitants avec les associations
dans les quartiers en difficulté
j'ai travaillé pour les développer ces
quartiers c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'aime les habitants j'aime s'attendre
et et j'y suis attaché
le département c'est à la fois une main
tendue et une main qui tire vers le haut
alors pour la main tendue moi je veux
qu'on révolutionne les aides
individuelles pour une vraie égalité des
chances et notamment dans le domaine de
l'habitat il faut que m on booste
l'amélioration de l'habitat ensuite je
veux accompagner les parents dans
l'exercice de leur fonction parentale et
enfin je veux créer une brigade sociale
qui va dans les quartiers à la rencontre
des habitants pour havre et
accompagnement global ça c'est pour la
main tendue pour la main qui tire vers
le haut j'ai une vision pour l'est qui
doit créer de la richesse et créent de
l'emploi d'abord avec un modèle agricole
qui valorisent les produits locaux et
les produits d'excellence qu'on peut
exporter ensuite avec la route des eaux
de l'est qui va nous permettre de
développer les mi pente et enfin il est
important de lancer des nouvelles
filières pour créer de l'emploi et pour
valoriser les atouts de l'est autour du
tourisme de la silver economy de
l'économie bleu et du recyclage des
déchets
d'abord le département concernant ses
missions c'est la collectivité qui est
la plus proche de l'humain elle
contribue à l'épanouissement et au
bien-être des habitants mais elle les
accompagne également dans des moments
difficiles et même dans des situations
d'urgence ensuite concernant les moyens
le département peut développer des
politiques publiques fortes
puissantes pour aider les habitants à
s'épanouir pour aider les habitants à
être heureux et à trouver leur place
dans la société réunionnaise